[MUSIC PLAYING]
LUV KOTHARI: My
name is Luv Kothari.
I'm a product manager
in Google Play Store.
I'm responsible for improving
our understanding of Android
apps, their content,
their capabilities,
and their attributes.
And with that understanding
and knowledge,
we're improving how
we connect users
with great digital experiences
and improve their lives.
ILYA FIRMAN: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ilya Firman.
I'm a software engineer on
the Actions on Google team.
Actions on Google offers
APIs for developers
to integrate with the Google
Assistant and other Google
products.
My focus is on bringing
Android apps into the Actions
on Google ecosystem.
LUV KOTHARI: So today, we
are super excited to give you
a sneak peek into App Actions.
As Dave mentioned in the
keynote this morning,
App Actions will allow users
to discover and reengage
with the capabilities and
content from your apps
in just the right moment.
And as an Android developer,
you will get an opportunity
to get surfaced across multiple
Google and Android surfaces
and improve engagement and
reach for your Android apps.
Let's look at a couple
of examples for this.
With App Actions, users
will be able to get things
done quickly and seamlessly.
Now, imagine you're
planning a Friday night out
with your friends.
Wouldn't it be great if you
had a personal assistant which
could help you accomplish
tasks such as making the dinner
reservation, getting
movie tickets,
getting a ride to the
venue, and building
a collage from the pictures
taken during the evening?
Now, Google Assistant
was created to help users
with these daily tasks.
And for many of
these tasks, the user
may already have the perfect
Android app on their devices.
With App Actions,
your Android app
can integrate with
Google Assistant
and participate in
these user journeys.
Moreover, these App
Actions suggestions
will also appear on other
Google and Android surfaces
to help users get
things done and discover
what their apps can do.
With App Actions,
users will also
be able to go from the content
they love to the Actions
they can take on that
content to the relevant apps
to fulfill those Actions.
Now, imagine a Lady Gaga fan is
searching for her latest hit.
Wouldn't it be
great if that user,
while searching for
that information,
could also discover where
to listen to her songs,
watch her videos, find
tickets for upcoming concerts,
and find a bit about her?
This is the ideal
moment for the user
to discover capabilities from
the Android apps they already
have.
App Actions can help users
re-engage with the apps
they forgot they had and also
discover new opportunities
and capabilities they
did not know existed.
We will be bringing
similar experiences
to diverse content such as TV
shows, movies, books, courses,
sports, games, books, and more.
As an Android developer,
you know that reengagement
is a challenging problem.
Users have hundreds of apps on
their devices to choose from.
Android has already did a
survey a couple of years ago
and found out that
77% of Android users
do not use an app after
three days of installing it.
And that number goes up
to 90% after a month.
You all have worked really
hard for those app installs,
but getting users to keep
coming back to your app
is a harder problem.
Now, notifications
and emails, they're
all tools in your toolkit.
But it's also possible
that they can come
across as spammy and annoying.
It's much better to
reengage with the user
in the right context
and in the right moment.
So today, we're going
beyond simply predicting
the next app the user would
want to open to the next Action
user would want to take.
In an AI-first world,
we want to assist
users to find capabilities
and content from your apps,
even if that information is
buried deep inside the app.
So how will we make this happen?
First, we're building a
rich catalog of Actions,
or intents, as we call them.
Essentially, think of
them as verb plus noun.
These are the ways
you will define
what your apps are capable of.
Some examples-- play
music, play game,
take calls, order
ride, order food.
These are all intents
in our catalog.
For these intents,
we will then build
deep semantic understanding.
Now, what do I mean by that?
We will define detailed
schemas with parameter specs
and also define grammar not
only in English but many
other languages.
Now, let's take a concrete
example of checking air quality
in Los Angeles.
There are multiple ways a
user can make that query.
Some examples are right here.
"Check pollution in LA."
"Find smog levels."
"Check air quality report."
"What's the forecast
for air pollution?"
And many other possible ways
a user can make that query.
Google will parse
all of these queries
and map them into one
common built-in intent
called CHECK_AIR_QUALITY.
We'll also parse the
right parameters,
such as location being Los
Angeles and time period
being today.
All of this will get
then passed along
to the Android
app, which can then
take the user to the
right place inside the app
and fulfill that Action.
As I said, we'll also define
grammars in popular languages
and provide natural
language understanding.
What's really
powerful about this
is that you get instant global
reach without actually having
to do the hard work of
understanding languages,
providing semantic
understanding.
We already support 16
languages and will continue
to expand our coverage.
How do you participate?
As an Android
developer, you just
need to add an Actions.xml
file in your APK.
In this file, you need to
register for the intents
that your app is capable
of and it supports
and tell us how to fulfill
those Actions via deep-links.
And Ilya will cover more of
exactly how you can do that.
Once you've exposed the
capabilities and content
of your apps, Google will then
map user queries and context
to your app and surface
you in multiple highly used
Google products,
starting from Android,
and within Android, the
launcher and smart text
selection, the Google Play
Store, the Google Assistant,
and the Search app.
Actions are not
restricted to Android P
and are available on all devices
with the most recent versions
of these apps.
Let's walk through
a few examples.
And by the way, I'm super
excited to be walking you
through these really
amazing features we
have worked really hard
for the last few months
to put together.
This is my screen on my
phone, the All Apps screen,
as we call it.
Last year, we
introduced the concept
of predicted [INAUDIBLE].
This is the operating
system trying
to predict the next app me, as
a user, would want to open up.
It's been working really great.
As Dave mentioned this
morning, we have about 60%
prediction rate on this.
It's phenomenal.
But this year, we
want to go further.
We want to go from
predicting the next app
to predicting the next Action
user would want to take.
So if you take a closer look,
I see two Action suggestions.
And right around
this time of the day,
I'm typically
commuting back home.
I'm relying on Google
Maps to navigate me
through the crazy
Bay Area traffic we
have to deal with around here.
I'm also talking to my wife,
Tina, catching up on our day
and mostly strategizing
on how to survive
with two kids at home.
Both of these Actions take
me deep inside the app
to fulfill the task immediately.
The Actions are predicted
based on my usage patterns,
my routines, my app sequences,
and also in the context
I'm in, whether I'm in my car,
whether I have my headset on,
what else I'm doing.
As another example, if I really
plug in my headset in my phone,
I'll get an Action to resume
an album or a playlist
that I was listening to
on my favorite music app.
Actions are also included
in smart text selection
in Android.
So let's say I get
a recommendation
to a new restaurant in the
city called Flour + Water.
And as I tap around
on that text,
smart text selection
will recognize
that it's a restaurant name
and select the whole text.
It will also try to map
what possible Actions
and then, further, what possible
apps can fulfill that Action
for that given entity.
So as I select Flour +
Water, I get a recommendation
to use OpenTable, which is an
app that I use a lot to make
reservations on my phone.
I can tap on that.
It will take me directly
into the OpenTable app, where
I can see more information, read
reviews, and make the dinner
reservation.
All of this is getting powered
using an on-device machine
learning model.
Any of that text that I'm
selecting on the screen
never leaves my device, so
everything is secure and fast.
Smart text selection's
neural network
will be able to recognize many
other entities, such as TV
shows, movies,
athletes, musicians,
flight numbers, and more.
Actions will also
surface in Play Store.
Now, what's really
phenomenal about this
is that we all know there
is an app for everything.
And the Play Store
is the place where
users go looking for those
apps and those capabilities.
So let's say I
search for Lady Gaga.
I will get Action suggestions
to go inside any of these apps
and fulfill those Actions.
Again, what's
interesting is not only
I get Action suggestions
for apps I have installed
but also the apps
I've not installed.
This is the universe of
apps that exist out there.
If I tap on something
that is not installed,
I'll go to the Details
page of that app.
I can then install the app.
And when I tap open, it'll
again take me directly
into the right place inside
the app to fulfill that Action.
With App Actions, users
can discover new ways
to reengage with the
content they already love.
Actions will also
work in Assistant.
So let's say I ask Assistant
to show me my budget on Mint.
Assistant will
understand that query
and parse it to "show budget"
Action inside the Android app.
And again, the right
place inside the app
will get invoked, and I'll be
able to fulfill that Action.
Here, I'm asking Assistant,
what is Lady Gaga's real name?
Now, of course, we'll
understand the question,
answer back with the
right information.
But the Assistant
can also anticipate
that I might be interested
in knowing more about Lady
Gaga and similar artists.
So I get shown Actions
such as where all I
can listen to her
songs, watch her videos,
buy tickets to her upcoming
concerts, back to the example
I showed earlier in
the presentation.
It's a great way for users
to discover capabilities
about the apps
they already have,
and they're able to do
so in the right moment.
Again, tapping on
any of these chips
will take me directly
into your Android apps
and then will let me fulfill
the Action I was intended to do.
Finally, as Dave mentioned
this morning in the keynote,
and you all saw this, we're
exploring different ways
to surface Actions in
Google Search for apps
that users already use a lot.
As an example, if you search
for the latest Avengers
movie, "Infinity
War," in addition
to regular suggestions,
you will now
get an Action to Fandango
app to buy tickets,
assuming Fandango is an
app that you use a lot
and you have it on your phone.
Really cool.
Changing gears a little,
Actions for App Actions
are built as part
of a broader Actions
on Google developer platform.
This platform provides common
development tools, processes,
and a set of building blocks,
foundational building blocks,
really.
An example of this you
already saw-- intent catalog.
This is the taxonomy
of some built
in intents for
which we'll provide
deep semantic understanding.
With structured data,
you can provide Google
the inventory for your Actions.
You can also report Action
usage via Firebase App Indexing
and get recommended in
personalized suggestions based
on context and usage patterns.
Identity and seamless
digital subscriptions
allow hassle-free transition
across multiple device form
factors and modalities.
The two modalities available--
number one, Android App Actions.
That's what we've been
talking about here.
There is another one, which
is conversational Actions.
And you've heard
quite a bit about it
in the consumer and
developer keynote.
These are the ones
for you to build
voice-powered experiences.
You can also join
a vertical program
and deeply integrate with
Google for enhanced discovery
across multiple Google surfaces.
So Google is defining a
rich catalog of intents
with schemas and grammars.
As a developer, you
sign up by providing us
an Actions.xml file, where
you can register for intents
that your app supports.
You also tell us how to fulfill
those intents via deep-links.
And once you have done that,
you get instant inquiries
and reach and engagement across
multiple Google and Android
surfaces.
Ilya, can you walk us
through some of this
and show us how this is working?
ILYA FIRMAN: Thank
you so much, Luv.
I hope you guys are
as excited as we
are about the opportunities
offered by App Actions.
You must be wondering,
how do I sign up?
Let me walk you step by step
through the process of setting
up Actions for your app.
At the core of App
Actions is Actions.xml,
a new configuration
file that you can
include in your Android APK.
Actions.xml enables you
to register for intents
and to define fulfillment
for those intents.
Now, when we talk about intents
in the context of Actions
on Google, we're talking
about semantic intents.
These are defined by the
Actions on Google platform.
These intents describe what
your Action does in a language
that Google can understand.
Intents can be built in,
coming from the rich catalog
of intents that Luv
mentioned earlier,
or custom intents that are
defined by the developer.
And while intents describe
what an Action does,
fulfillment describes how
your app does that Action.
For Android apps, fulfillment
connects the semantic intent
to the Android
intent in the app.
Together, intents and
fulfillment define Actions.
And Actions.xml
is how you provide
Actions in your Android app.
Once you've defined your
intents and your fulfillment,
you can help us personalize
Action suggestions
by integrating usage logging
into your app using APIs
from Firebase App Indexing.
You can also extend your
reach beyond Android
by building
conversational Actions.
And you can enhance the
way Actions are presented
to the user using Slices, a
new UI framework for surfacing
deep in-app content.
This is just a quick
high-level overview
of the App Actions
set up process.
Let us now walk through
each step in detail,
starting with intents.
As Luv mentioned
earlier, App Actions
is built up on a new
catalog of semantic intents
that are published by Google
as part of the Actions
on Google platform.
For each intent,
we define a grammar
that helps us recognize user
queries and parameters that we
can infer from the query
and pass into your app.
The intent catalog helps us
organize the world of Actions
so we can show the right
Actions to the right user
at the right time.
We expect that most developers
will register for one
of our built-in intents.
With built-in intents, you give
Google a deep understanding
of what your app does.
Moreover, with
built-in intents, you
don't need to worry about
natural language understanding.
I imagine, after I/O, you might
want to ask your Assistant
to get a ride to SFO or book a
taxi to San Francisco airport
or to order a cab to the
San Francisco airport.
With built-in intents,
you don't need
to worry about all the different
ways in which a user can
express the same intent.
Google takes care of natural
language understanding.
Your app just needs to
provide fulfillment.
Built-in intents
give you support
from many languages
right out of the box,
and they provide a one-stop
shop for getting access
to multiple UI surfaces.
We will be adding
more and more intents
into the catalog over time.
So if your particular
use case is not covered,
chances are it will be soon.
And you will have
a way to request
new intents to be defined.
And if your use case
is truly unique,
you can define a custom intent
and build your own grammar
using Actions Console,
the equivalent
of Play Console for Actions
on Google developers.
It is important to distinguish
between semantic intents that
are defined by Actions on Google
and Android intents, a feature
in the Android framework.
As Android developers,
you're probably
familiar with Android intents.
They describe specific
Android operations
in a way that allows Android
apps to talk to each other.
Semantic intents,
on the other hand,
are part of our larger catalog
that extends beyond Android
and includes their
system, Google
Search, and other surfaces.
For Android apps,
Actions.xml is what
defines the mapping
between semantic intents
and specific Android
intents in your app.
Of course, you can
build multiple ways
to fulfill the same semantic
intent across different types
of devices.
For example, let's
say you're a bank,
and you want to support the
"check account balance" intent.
On Android, your
mobile banking app
is a great way to
support that intent.
But separately, you can
build a conversational Action
so you can support a
voice-only experience
on Google Home or smart displays
using the tools that you've
seen earlier in the
Actions on Google talk.
And if you'd like to
learn more about how
to transition from building
for your Android app
to building conversational
experiences,
you can come to a session
dedicated to that on Thursday
morning.
Today, we will
focus specifically
on integrating your Android apps
into the App Actions ecosystem.
Now, if you're an
Android developer,
you've probably already
familiar with intent filters,
a native mechanism
in the Android
to expose intents
outside of the app.
Intent filters define
content types and data URIs
that your app can accept.
And those data URIs
can come in the form
of HTTP URLs, or perhaps
URLs in your own custom
app-specific scheme.
Actions.xml defines how a
semantic intent inferred
from a user's query
or the user's context
can be converted into a
URL to open in your app.
Android's intent
filter logic then
converts that URL into a
specific Android intent
to launch in your app.
Now, why do we use URLs to
connect semantic intents
and Android intents?
Deep-link URLs are part of a
larger app discovery ecosystem.
You can link your
app URLs to your web
content using verified
app links or site maps.
With Google's structured
data programs,
you can precisely define
the specific content
that your app can support.
And with Firebase
App Indexing, you
can enable Google to
personalize Action suggestions
by identifying what users
do when they use your app.
All of these different
features and programs
use URLs to identify
content in your app.
So we've talked about intents.
Now, let's switch gears
and talk about fulfillment.
Fulfillment describes
a specific mechanism
to invoke a particular
Action in your app.
Fulfillment is what
tells Google how
to determine the specific
deep-link URL to open
for a given semantic intent.
With Actions.xml, you
can use one of two models
to provide fulfillment
for a semantic intent.
In the URL template
model, we use
the parameters of
the semantic intent
to dynamically construct a
fulfillment URL at runtime.
Actions.xml provides
a URL template
with placeholders for
specific parameters.
At runtime, we then take those
parameters from the user intent
and pass them into your URL.
This model is ideal
for Action-centric apps
with deep-link APIs.
In the content-driven model,
we discover the fulfillment URL
through your web content
or your structured data.
We use the user's query to
find the relevant content
in your web
presence, and then we
use Actions.xml to connect
the URL of that content
with appropriate intent.
Of course, you must verify
ownership of your web content
before you can use
it in your app.
You can use Android's
verified app links
or connect your app with your
website using the Google Search
Console.
All that's really needed for
content-driven fulfillment
is linking your Actions.xml
to your web pages.
But the content-driven
fulfillment model
works best with structured data.
While semantic intents
describe the verbs
that your app supports,
structured data
can describe the nouns,
the inventory of your app.
Google provides a variety
of structured data programs.
Some of them use web markup.
Some of them use
hosted data feeds.
Many of you probably already
participate in these programs.
You can use our structured
data developer site
to see if there is a
vertical program that
fits your specific use
case, and you can also
find a link to the tool that
you can use to test your markup.
So how do you actually submit
your Actions.xml to Google?
Perhaps you're developing your
app in the Android studio,
and you can include your
Actions.xml in the same Android
project, in the same APK that
you submit to the Play Console.
Play Console parses
your Actions.xml
and registers your Actions in
the Actions on Google database.
This registration allows your
app to respond to queries
and appear in suggestions
in various Google products.
And how can you test that
your Actions work before you
submit your app to Play?
You can use our new plug-in
for the Android Studio,
called the App
Actions Text Tool.
With this tool, you can
validate your Actions.xml
and submit it to
Actions on Google
in the special
preview mode, which
makes your Actions available
just for your own developer
account.
You can then test how Google
Assistant would invoke your app
with different combinations
of semantic intent parameters.
But enough talk.
Let's take a look at some demos.
In this first example,
I will show you
how the URL template-based
fulfillment model works.
I will show you my
favorite taxi app
that I built a couple of weeks
ago for this session integrates
with the ORDER_RIDE
built-in intent.
Can we switch to slides
for just one moment?
Switch to slides?
Thank you.
The ORDER_RIDE intent
comes with four parameters
for pickup location, drop
off location, pickup time,
and drop off time.
Each of these parameters is
defined as a schema.org entity.
And you can see on
the slide how we
parse the parameters of that
entity from a user invocation.
And now, let's
switch to the laptop.
So what you can see on your
screen is Android Studio.
And in my Android project, I
have my Actions.xml file open.
You can see here that
I'm registered in my taxi
app for the ORDER_RIDE intent.
And I'm providing
a URL template.
In this case, it happens
to be an HTTP URL,
but you can also use
app-specific URLs or intent
URIs.
And in this case,
there are placeholders
in the URL template for two
parameters-- for the drop
off and pickup address.
These parameters are then
mapped to the parameters
of the intent.
The placeholders are mapped to
the parameters of the intent.
Now, let's bring up the
App Actions Test Tool.
When I click the
Load Actions button,
the tool will validate
my Actions.xml,
parse it, and
submit it to Actions
on Google in preview mode.
So I can test what
would happen if I passed
that particular parameter.
When I click Run--
oops.
For some reason,
my phone decided
to switch in landscape mode.
But OK, I think
I made the point.
The tool passes a
parameter to the app.
And the way this
happens is the tool
simulates what Google
Assistant would
do if it received the
particular semantic intent
with particular parameters.
More specifically, the tool
constructs an Action link.
And you might have seen
Action links earlier today
in the Actions on Google talk.
This is a deep-link
to a specific semantic
intent in the Assistant.
Let's switch the slides, please.
We've talked about the
template-based fulfillment
model.
Now, let's talk a
little bit about how
the content-driven model works.
We have worked with Coursera
to integrate their app
with App Actions.
Coursera is signing up
for the TAKE_COURSE intent
from our catalog.
This intent, today, takes
a single parameter of type
schema.org/course.
And you can see how we are
parsing properties of that
schema.org/course from
a user invocation.
Now, Coursera happens to
annotate all of their course
web pages with structured data.
And we can infer from
the structured data
what the name of the course
is, what the course is about,
and what the specific deep-link
URL for that course is.
And since Coursera is
using verified app links,
we can use the same URL to open
the Coursera app on the device.
Let's switch to
the laptop, please.
Thank you.
Here is what Actions.xml
could look like for Coursera.
Coursera is signing up for
the TAKE_COURSE intent.
And for the course
parameter of that intent,
there is an inventory reference,
an entity set reference,
that ties this
indent registration
to schema.org/course structures
located on these web pages.
And the URL template,
in this case,
just takes the URL discovered
from structured data
as a referrer param.
Again, we can bring up
the App Actions Test Tool,
submit Actions in preview mode.
And let's see what
would happen if I wanted
to study machine learning.
The Coursera app opens
to the specific deep-link
for the machine learning course.
And if demo gods smile
at us, perhaps we
can also see what would
happen if I try to query,
"what is deep learning?"
So here, the system has given
us a knowledge answer explaining
what deep learning is.
But underneath
that answer, there
is a suggestion to learn more by
taking a course with Coursera.
And when I click
on that link, it
opens a specific deep-link to
a course in the Coursera app.
Let's switch back
to slides, please.
So you've seen how you
can define your intents
and fulfillment using the
Actions.xml configuration file.
You can further help
people discover your apps
by integrating usage
logging into your app using
Firebase App Indexing APIs.
Action logging through
as App Indexing
helps Google provide
personalized suggestions
based on the user's context
and the usage patterns.
For example, if you often
listen to jazz music
on your evening
commute, it may show you
a suggestion to play
cool jazz radio when
you get into the car.
Or if we know that you keep
watching "Altered Carbon,"
we may give you a
helpful suggestion when
the next episode comes out.
Action logging can help
your app rank better
in these personalized
Action suggestions.
This is not a new API.
We have made changes
to the API specifically
to support App Actions.
You can now tie
each reported event
to a specific semantic intent
and specific parameter values.
Of course, users remain
in control of their data
at all times.
They can see and control
all of their logged activity
using the My Activity
website, and they can opt out
of Action logging altogether.
I will now pass
the stage to Luv,
who will talk to you
about how you can enhance
your Actions by adding a rich UI
and conversational fulfillment.
LUV KOTHARI: Thank you, Ilya.
And thank you, demo gods.
This was amazing to see this
happening in front of us,
and it was incredible.
I want to give a big shout
out to multiple teams,
multiple product teams,
that have worked together
on this feature.
I mean, if you imagine, right?
You have Android as a
developer ecosystem,
and you've got
Actions on Google.
It's never easy
when you try to make
both of these ecosystems
work together as seamlessly
as you have just seen here.
To recap, as a developer, you
can participate in Actions
by registering your
app and the Actions
in your app in the
Actions.xml file.
You can provide
fulfillment with URLs,
either a URL template
or as structured data.
You can report Action usage
using Firebase App Indexing
to help your app rank better.
However, App Actions
as we think of it
is just the first step in
your journey with Actions.
There are more
ways with which you
can enhance Actions and further
increase engagement with users.
First, you can use Slices to
enhance Action representation
through rich UI templates.
And second, you can build
conversational experiences
and multimodality experiences
for Google Assistant.
Let's take a quick look.
Slices enhance Action
presentation through templates.
These templates are
designed to appear
outside the app
in Android system
UI, like notifications, or
in other Google platforms,
like Assistant and Search.
These templates support flexible
layouts, interactive controls,
like sliders and toggles,
and dynamic data,
like real-time pricing
served directly
from the app on
the user's phone.
Slices are compatible with
devices on API 19 or above.
Essentially, it enables
you to get to about 95%
of Android devices
that are out there.
Pretty cool.
This year's Slices are launched
on Google Search on Android.
If you want to learn more,
we have a whole session
dedicated to Slices.
It's tomorrow at
8:30 on stage 4.
Hope to see you there.
But what about all these new
devices and platforms that
are coming into
market, things that you
heard from Brad in developer
keynote this afternoon?
You can extend your
services to new devices
and form factors by building
conversational Actions
and multimodality experiences
for Google Assistant.
Again, to learn more, please
attend our technical session
on Thursday morning
at 10:30 on stage 4.
Actually, it's 9:30.
My bad.
So hope you are as excited
about this project as we are.
Many Android
developers are already
building support for Actions,
and hope you will, as well.
If you're interested, please
let us know at g.co/AppActions.
You can learn more about
the project on that page.
Sign up for further
updates, newsletters.
We'll be starting an early
access program next month.
Hopefully, some of you
will sign up for that.
We'd love to hear your
feedback and very specifically
on built-in intents,
the catalog that we're
building for intents.
Over the next two days,
you have quite a few venues
to answer any burning
questions that you have.
We have presence
in Office Hours.
We have presence in both
sandboxes in Android,
as well as Assistant,
where we can
show you more of these things
live and answer any questions
that you have.
Again, we have
two more sessions,
one on Slices tomorrow
morning and one
on conversational Actions
on Assistant the day
after tomorrow.
And fairly soon, you'll be
able to upload the Actions.xml
file on your app using
Play Developer Console.
Thank you.
Love to hear from you.
If you have any feedback,
give it to us on this website.
Thank you so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]